près de 11000 gramoune ont fait le
déplacement pour profiter de cette
journée départementale des personnes
âgées
au programme visite du village sport
santé et bien-être où notre troisième
jeunesse prend le temps de se détendre
on propose les brushings onglerie voilà
les personnes âgées sont contents eh oui
vient ensuite un rendez vous
incontournable de cette journée la messe
du père lilian payet
à midi nos gramounes ont pris place sous
les arbres centenaires du jardin de
l'état
le temps d'un pique nique des tabacs
passer un bon moment
tu m'as balisage
c'est en famille ou entre amis
camara des voyages des familles d'accord
très vite la voix de natacha tortillard
entraîne aux aînés vers la scène pour un
bal la poussière
non
la journée départementale des personnes
âgées c'est aussi un village agricole
des stands d'information et de
prévention l'occasion pour le
département de rappeler ces actions
menées au plus près de nous unir l'enjeu
c'est bien de bien vieillir
l'enjeu c'est bien de continuer à être
heureux le plus longtemps possible
quand nous sommes élus pourquoi ne les
ai vus nous les élus pour travailler que
de moon les heureux alors n'est pas
facile c'est aller vrai challenge mais
nous nous les élus par le peuple de
pouce à pendant cette mandature ce qu'on
va faire ce qu'on va mettre en avant
c'est la prévention de la dépendance
parce que quand on prévient comme on dit
en créole vaut mieux prévenir que guérir
donc si on prévient avant
automatiquement le gramoune et va mieux
vieillir c'est l'objectif principal
ensuite faire en sorte que même si
dépendance il ya la personne âgée puisse
vieillir paisiblement par la création de
ces fameuses maisons d'accueil emporia
que nous allons mettre en place